as it turns out I have the brain pattern
of a psychopath
I've got the genes like all of them that
would make me a very violent dangerous
person it's just kind of a quirk I'm a
neuroscientist and my research my
interests have been half an adult stem
cells throughout my career and also
psychiatry within psychiatry very
interested in the genetics of
psychiatric disorders schizophrenia
depression and also as part of that for
the past about 18 years my colleagues
have given me imaging pictures of brains
of killers we're in trial or you know
going to trial and send they say what's
he what do you see
the working hypothesis is that there are
three key ingredients for
psychopathology including of
psychopathic killers for example these
three things first genetics and that is
that they carry one or more there's at
least ten of them but one or more of
these high-risk violence-related genes
the second part is some sort of loss of
brain function of an area of the frontal
lobe right above the iSchool orbital
cortex that's the area that codes for
it's in the circuit that codes for
ethics and morality conscience when
that's gone it or never develops a
person doesn't have a good sense of
ethics and morality but also it controls
impulse those impulse control so usually
people with this kind of damage not only
don't have an ethics or morality or
conscience about what they're doing but
they also very impulsive about it that's
the second thing so it's a brain damage
to genetics
the third key thing is abuse and how
that early childhood abuse very severe
abuse sexual emotional physical abuse
those three things put together seem to
be the key elements and when they happen
when the brain damaged have when the
abuse happens is thought to be involved
with the kind of site the psychopath you
have
genetics in the past two years has
undergone a revolution that's quite
incredible and now we're able to use
mathematical models and really associate
networks of genes that people have and
the risk for all sorts of behavior you
know from ulcers all the way up to
psychopathology I think it's going to
have a tremendous impact from this day
forward in understanding psychopathology
and perhaps out used in the law too we
have a convicted felon kind of you know
can that felon just say look at better
my my brain made me do yeah they make
sure your brain made you do it
but is it something you have any control
over this is a question that for every
person is going to be a different answer
in a sense yeah the brain made them do
it
but does that mean that they're not
responsible for the activity no that
does not mean they're not responsible
for what they did you can explain it and
say I did it for that you're so fine I'm
you know it's too bad we're sorry about
that but we have to put you away you
know if it goes that way so but it still
helps you understand the person why they
did it if you don't want how it came
about it may not affect how long they're
in jail or anything else but at least we
know and they know maybe can help them
I think one has to be careful on how you
define freewill if you take the second
path of killers for example they may
kill when they're 18 and then they may
kill again when they're 28 well where
they express you know with a showing
much freewill during that time period
but then they kill three more people in
eight more people twenty years ago by
and they've killed 35 people one could
say in those times they weren't killing
that freewill and they were suppressing
it I don't look at it exactly that way I
look at the whole pattern of behavior
and say you know it's just like going to
the bathroom you may put it off you may
put it off but it's going to happen in
that sense I really don't think there's
much free will that's really in play
there a psychopath is somebody who is
not really in control they have a you
know very flat affect the way they
relate to people is very different they
they're pretty much cold and aloof but
they're being very charming too they can
put on a great act and so they can show
some control but part of it is
manipulation - so ultimately they're
they may not be in control really as in
the sense we think of ultimately what
they're going to do but they have enough
control little pieces of their behavior
that they can navigate through the world
in pretty bad ways
it'll be interesting to see how what
role ultimately neuroscience plays in
public policy the problem for scientists
or neuro scientists is we now know more
and more about not only the genetics but
how every person is really an individual
there's no two people alike even into
even identical twins are not identical
now to treat everybody individually
everybody becomes a special case this is
not what you want public policy public
policies you apply standard and really
in a sense there is no standard to a
neuroscientist because everybody's
different it's a bit like Big Pharma
wanting one pill to take care of
depression and one pill to take care of
ADHD and one pill to take care of
infection it turns out they've come
kicking and screaming into accepting the
past year too
that they're this individualized
medicine that everybody is different
everybody reacts to drugs differently
some drugs work wonderfully but they
can't use that one drug any more for
that one syndrome it's a good business
model but it's bad neurosciences banned
clinical medicine the same way
governments tend to treat everybody as
the same you know they have to in a way
it's an even fair applicational law but
this violates all the individuality that
is really in US and it really is very
limiting
you know how the law is an asset at a
very fundamental level I think
government is an asset a very
fundamental level that is not
commensurate with the individual
potential human potential way beyond
what we thought it was it's unworkable
my mother set it up barbecue that we had
family barbecue she pulled me aside she
said the you know you pillows talks were
enrolled on the country not psychopathic
killers you got to watch out what you
say because it turns out there's this
book that just came out on your family
the Cornell's and she said in this book
there was a line of seven killers from
them to you starting 1667 with Thomas
Cornell who killed his mother Lizzie
Borden was a famous case in the late
19th century she is well known for
chopping up her parents and mother and
father took an axe and killed them she's
a cousin apart so this is whole dark
history of violence and murder and her
family as it turns out I have the brain
pattern of a psychopath I've got the
genes like all of them that would make
me a very violent dangerous person but
that doesn't mean somebody with this
pattern where the frontal lobe orbital
cortex turned off is going to be a
killer it means that they're going to
have probably a flat emotional effect
we're going to be superficially charming
usually risk takers which I am bold
vivants which I am can be clowns which I
am and but you also see this in
sociopaths and Psychopaths Toula they
have the superficial charm and so there
is some overlap it's just that I'm not
I'm not violent but I hate to lose at
Scrabble you know I I plain get
sublimated I guess a little bit and the
one thing that isn't there the one
ingredient is I was never abused and I
had a wonderful childhood that
apparently protected me in some way from
this kind of funky biology
I'm a happen to be a libertarian have
been since nineteen seventy you know
with with people like libertarians there
were so logical it's a very strong
dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex which
is right here
and this whole stream going it's almost
like a yarmulke or hat that you'd wear
it's the area right under a yarmulke
alright though that's really the cold
cognition and you know reason an
executive function this is the group
where you'd see maybe there'd be nothing
going on down here too much like the
psychopath but this would be so strong
that they could reason away conflicts
okay so maybe that's true it'd be worth
looking at I think it'd be a fascinating
study because but nobody ever looks at
libertarians brains that's for sure